il reste douze mois à barack obama pour
solidifier son héritage sa place aux
états unis comme 44e président barack
obama lui parle d'une partie de football
qui se termine et dick souvent dans les
dernières minutes c'est là où les choses
les plus intéressantes se passe sur la
scène internationale bien sûr ce qui va
beaucoup retenir l'attention du
président à toutes les semaines
peut-être même à tous les jours c'est
bien sûr toute cette guerre contre le
groupe armé état islamique et à ce qu'on
fait militairement là-dessus barack
obama a l'impression que les américains
ne comprennent pas sa stratégie que la
sienne elle est la bonne mais que les
américains comprennent pas donc il devra
peut-être vendre cette stratégie leur un
peu mieux mais en même temps peut être
intensifiées tout ce qui se fait sur le
terrain est un processus diplomatique un
processus de paix en syrie aussi qui
pourrait peut-être à coucher sur quelque
chose ça fait partie de la solution mais
sur le président le poids simplement
penser au moyen orient elle pensera
aussi à la poursuite des listes
d'initiatives diplomatiques comme ce qui
a été l'ouverture avec cuba mais aussi
le traité sur le nucléaire iranien
sur la scène intérieure sur la scène
américaine 2015 a été quand même assez
intéressante pour le président la cour
suprême va aider beaucoup deux grandes
décisions en protégeant sa réforme sur
la santé et en permettant le mariage gay
dans tous les états aux états unis donc
ça l'a aidé les positions du président
américain 2016 par contre risque d'être
plus difficile sur la scène intérieure
surtout parce que nous sommes en année
électorale
là les républicains vont faire tout ce
qu'ils peuvent pour mettre des bâtons
dans les roues du président de tous les
démocrates barack obama depuis le début
de son mandat n'est pas capable de
resserrer le contrôle des armes à feu
il ya eu plusieurs massacres à chaque
fois le président a lancé des appels les
élus au congrès ne bouge pas barack
obama entendent 2016 en tentant de le
faire par lui-même de resserrer le
contrôle des armes à feu avec son
pouvoir de président
il y aura aussi la question de la
justice pénale donc une réforme de
certaines des peines amoindrir des
peines
là barack obama à désespoir d'entente
avec le congrès avec les républicains
parce que les deux parties s'entendent
un peu sur la question donc un peu
d'espoir de ce côté là mais un des
grands facteurs en fait qui va motiver
le président dans cette dernière année
c'est s'assurer qu'il y ait un ou une
démocrate à la maison blanche en 2016
parce que si le prochain président et
républicains une bonne partie de
l'héritage de barack obama pourrait tout
simplement s'envoler en fumée dès 2017